now live at 6 30. well throughout the
entire election multiple groups and
campaigns targeted the latino community
some such as latinos for trump and
me familiavota who say 2020 was a very
unique year for the latino vote 8 news
now reporter sally jaramillo has more on
latino voter turnout
and campaign efforts voting to me is
the one power that's keeping us from
facing
an existential crisis people have long
said latino voters are not monolithic
and it's very true
professor of urban affairs at unlv
robert lang says there's a lot of
difference between florida latinos
and those in arizona and nevada florida
has a lot of caribbean or south american
latinos
who are quite conservative you know
coming from countries like
cuba and venezuela that the sort of
trump charge of anyone's a socialist
that's not trump
lang says caribbean and south american
latinos appear more positive towards the
republican party
than latinos in the rest of the country
laying at it yesterday
he was impressed with the number of
latino voters in the valley
the numbers look good you know they were
up generally with other groups as well
but yeah this is a year that latinos
helped determine the fate of the
election
ceo of mifamilia vota hector sanchez
varva agrees
throughout the six states they have
operations that include florida
texas nevada colorado arizona
and california he saw historical numbers
almost 9 million in early voting just
the fact
that young latinos latinos from 19 to 29
came out in historical numbers it
increased 300 percent on the young
latino vote
that by itself is a national story varva
says he is pleased with the work mi
family avota did throughout the nation
together they placed 4.9 million calls
2.6 million text messages
and knocked on five thousand doors when
we educate our community
they turn out to vote latinos were eager
to work
during this election in nevada and they
did